I recently attended assessment for
retraining into the combat control
career field I'm active duty for Air
Force in a different career field and
rang the bell
during water confidence training how do
I live with my decision and move forward
yeah and there's you see there's two
there's two questions that are basically
the same question so that was part a and
this is Part B I do read do hard deal
art okay drop on request
gotcha wearing the belt same thing so ID
lard from buds class 303 I went went on
to be a SAR CORS CORS miss our swimmer
star swimmer corpsman so here's a who's
a rescue swimmer okay
but it's Tatum but it's taken until
recently to regain the desire to live
and even strive to work out again what
can you do when you realize a life path
you've chosen was not only wrong but you
never feel like you found a new path to
me this this question both these
questions are kind of similar to the
previous one right and I can tell you
being a being a seal or being a combat
controller is not the be-all end-all and
the bottom line is it wasn't for you it
wasn't for you it wasn't even you don't
you guys it just wasn't for you and the
fact that matters it's not for most
people it's not normal there's an 80%
attrition rate of births most people
quit good people I was down there the
other day and was talking one of my
buddies that runs runs it runs he's a
civilian reason of the civilians that
works there but he was we were talking
about you know what it about buds and I
forget what even led into it but he
pointed at that you know when you when
you quit but you put your helmet by the
Bell and so as more and more people quit
important more helmets are enough and
there'll be hundreds of helmets lined up
and he's like you see those helmets
right there and I'm like yeah he goes
every single one of those kids was a
stud and when I went through it wasn't
quite like that because not everyone
that was shown up at Budds in the 90s
was a stud the they weren't because we
didn't know what was happening
we didn't know we didn't know how to do
a pull-up workout we couldn't look
online and see a program on how to get
better at rope climbs we didn't know
that you had to swim with fins we didn't
know I didn't know what I don't know
anything when I showed up to buds so
these kids now they know everything and
so what do they do they prepare all of
them at a minimum I would say the
minimum guy prepared now is probably
prepared at least as good as the most
prepared guy actually that's probably
that's probably inaccurate I bet you the
minimum the least prepared guy entering
buds right now is probably still more
prepared than the most prepared guy that
went to buds when I went through now so
so my point in saying that is most of
those people that are studs quit most of
those people that join the Navy that
sign on a dotted line and commit six
years of their life because there's
nothing more they want to do than be a
seal and most of them don't make it
through so it's not for everyone and
then you know what you you've one guy in
the airforce one guy in the Navy you did
your job you did we're supposed to do a
corpsman whatever your normal career
field was in the Air Force and you
served your country and you did what the
country needed you to do the country
needs you to do whatever job you did the
country needed you to do that job so
thank you for your service and now you
go and find something else you go and
find a new mission and the same things
here like you you want to get better
with your life so what do you do you
work and you build and you study and you
get an awesome physical condition and
you train jujitsu and you become a
doctor or a firefighter or EMT you're a
cop and there's whichever way that you
figure out that you can serve you become
a businessperson you go and work
construction whatever it is that you do
you go and do it you do it harder you
don't get caught up in a title right so
this is another thing this kind of
reflects back to what we were talking
earlier seals don't care that you
weren't a seal you know like it's not
like seals or
walking around going oh this person
wasn't a seal I don't respect him this
person wasn't a seal I don't respect him
we don't care it's a vocation it's a job
so you're not I don't look down on
people that weren't seals it's just that
was my job you had a different job right
it's it's like it's like jujitsu I don't
look down on people that don't train
jujitsu I look at them like hey you
should because that's a choice mm-hmm
but let me rephrase that
I don't look down on people that I can
beat in jujitsu because I know for a
fact all it is is that I've been
training longer than them and once they
train longer than me they'll be able to
beat me that's the way it works
so people that were in the SEAL Teams
aren't looking down on you cuz you
weren't they don't care I'm not thinking
about it so when I meet a cop when I
meet a firefighter when I meet a
business person I respect what they're
doing with their life if they're getting
after it I don't care what arena it's in
man I know some ID I'm so lucky right
now working national on front we meet
people that are just just awesome humans
that are crushing their field and if
they were in the SEAL Teams they'd be
crushing that field but they didn't they
went to what they went and did what they
did they went in the finance world they
went in the construction world they went
in the gas oil business whatever they
did they did and they're getting after
it so that's what you need to do you
quit in the past you rang the bell
no one cares unless you quit now
so get up go find a new mission and get
after it man get after it